we cannot be dragged backward uh by uh
the very dangerous lies of a former
president spare me there are greater
threats to the country right now you may
have noticed
they need trump trump is a distraction
and liz cheney will substitute for trump
you can see how the media are swiveling
away from this so you have middle
eastern flames you have massive
inflation
you have an economy that is in the
doldrums even though we should be
in the greatest period of economic
growth of our lifetimes and bar none
right we were expecting that gdp growth
this quarter was going to be just
astounding and instead we got job growth
that was
three quarters of a million jobs under
what it was supposed to be this month
all of that is happening they're pushing
for radical social policy that shifts
the nature of the deal between
individual americans and the federal
government they're invading religious
freedom rights they're invading
the the ability of corporations to
operate as they want to with regard to
with regard to free markets like this
this administration is a bleep show and
the consequences are obvious to everyone
and so they are deeply reliant on joe
biden so the media
who are basically they're not basically
they just are the pr wing of the
democratic party that's all they are the
establishment media
understand there is no distinction
whatsoever between the dnc press office
and the actual press there's no
distinction they are the same the same
people occupy the same positions which
is why they move so smoothly from one to
the other you'll see people working for
the new york times and then suddenly
they just pop up
boom right there in the bible
administration you see it on cnn all the
time
it's not rare okay so they've decided
that they are going to misdirect away
from the chaos that has been engulfing
pretty much everywhere
and they are going to misdirect toward
this liz cheney story now
as i've been saying does anyone know who
the number three house minority party
leader was
like five years ago can you name the
person having trouble are you
yeah because no one cares who cares who
the number three is
in the house minority party you're not
talking about the house majority party
talking about the house minority party
but liz cheney is getting all sorts of
press because yesterday
liz cheney was voted out of her position
as the number three not the number two
and not the number one she was voted out
as the number three
in the house minority party specifically
because the republicans in the house
were getting frustrated with the fact
that liz cheney seemed to have a
peculiar prediction for the strange new
respect offered by the media
two months ago they voted on whether liz
cheney should stay she had exactly the
same position on january 6 then
that she does now she had exactly the
same position on
donald trump then than she does now she
had exactly the same position
on the veracity of the 2020 election
then as she does now but she withstood
the vote and
did so pretty easily with the support by
the way of kevin mccarthy the house
minority leader
then what happened she decided you know
it'd be a great idea i'm going to go
into the media and pretty much every day
i'm just only going to talk
about how trump sucks and how
republicans who supported trump kind of
suck and how the 2020 election is legit
and january 6th was the worst thing that
ever happened
and all of this now when you're the
house minority leader
when where when you're the house number
three i should say you have a couple of
jobs
okay and and those jobs are sometimes in
conflict
your job as a congress person is to vote
on issues liz cheney when she votes
is quite good she voted like 94 of the
time by the way with donald trump when
trump was president
so she actually had a better record of
voting with trump than the new house
number three
uh who is the kind of aspiring house
uh elise stefanik from new york cheyney
is much more conservative in voting
record than stephanie barnon
but it's not just about your voting
record it's about can you raise money
for the party and
do you help orient the communications of
the party toward taking down the
opposing party or
are you directing all of your fire
internally are you spending all of your
time giving msnbc and cnn and the
washington post in the new york times
exactly what they want
now there is a difference between how
you message
and what you message okay i have said
many times on the show
that i agree with liz cheney's basic
basic take
on january 6th i agree with her basic
take on how the election of 2020 went i
don't think it was decided by voter
fraud and irregularity
i think that if there was rigging it was
by the media which lied consistently for
years
i think that trump's behavior between
the election and january 6th was pretty
egregious i talked about it openly at
the time
i talk about it openly now and i agree
with all those things
but let's be real about this the threat
to the country is not coming
from a president who has not been in
office for four months is banned from
twitter and facebook and has been
relegated to starting a blog
and then blasting out emails about how
much he hates liz cheney
these kind of bizarre emails okay that
guy is not the deep threat to the
country the threat to the country
is an authoritarian left that has taken
over every major institution in american
life
is on the move at the top of the
american government is creating
inflation
unemployment and chaos in the middle
east this
that is the threat why is liz cheney not
talking about that okay that is the
specific reason why she was ousted
again she had the same positions that
she does now two months ago and she
survived the vote
then she decided i'm gonna use the
intervening eight weeks to do nothing
but crap on republicans and republicans
predictably were like
you know what we don't need you in house
leadership that's not a thing that we
require
we can have any other republican who's a
better fundraiser than you and doesn't
spend all their days
trying to give joe scarbrough all sorts
of uh
of fever dreams like try try not to do
that if you're in house leadership
okay so cheney has been doing this thing
where she basically
has made herself hero of the republic
strange new respect recipient
from the left and she has done so by
suggesting that the reason that she's
being asked from house leadership is not
because for lack of what we would call
hebrew seiko
her lack of common sense the reason
she's being ousted from house leadership
is because specifically she took this
position
well it's a combo right she did take a
position that is fairly
unpopular with the republican base but
she could survive that
she could she absolutely could survive
that position if
she did not make her top priority the
the
consistent weird take that the great
threat to the country is a president who
is no longer in office
and is not widely influential
via his blog okay like there are greater
threats to the country right now you may
have noticed
okay but liz cheney has decided that she
she kind of went into this thing without
an exit strategy
she decided she was gonna start this
fight and she really didn't know how to
get out of it so the only way to get out
of it
is to keep on doubling down so here she
was yesterday
talking about how today's show vote
shows where the gop is
no what today's vote shows or
yesterday's vote showed is that the gop
does not wish to spend all waking
moments talking about a guy who's
not in office that if they ignore
whatever silly things
trump is saying in his emails and focus
in on you know the crises facing the
country
they'll win back the house but you liz
cheney have spent every waking moment
apparently
dealing with trump i don't understand
why and no one else does either
but this is exactly what the media want
what the media want they know the only
way that democrats are able to retain
the house in 2022
is by labeling the republicans too crazy
to be elected
right to say that the republicans there
the party of trump now that's a real
bank shot cause trump ain't gonna have
been in office for a couple of years by
2022.
but that's really their only hope
because their own records sucks
the entire media is looking for this too
because they would much rather cover liz
cheney versus kevin mccarthy and the
republicans then cover the fact that a
doddering old president who doesn't know
what the hell is going on is presiding
over a bizarrely timed collapse on
nearly every front
so here's liz cheney giving the media
exactly what they want
do you feel betrayed by today's vote i
do not i think that
it is an indication of where the
republican party is
and i think that the party is in a place
that we've got to bring it back from
and we've got to get back to a position
where uh we are a party that can fight
for conservative principles that can
fight for substance
we cannot be dragged backward uh by uh
the very dangerous lies of a former
president okay i have a question
who's dragging us backward who's talking
about this the most who decides that
it's important to answer
every single question the media asks you
about this sort of stuff and spend 90
percent of your time on it
there are two ways that you're dragged
backwards here okay one she's correct
you shouldn't go ahead you shouldn't go
around
suggesting that trump's prevarications
are not for varications they were
you shouldn't go around suggesting that
biden in the president binds the
president
okay but there's another way you're
dragged backwards and that is
re-litigating this thing over and over
and over as though it makes a damn bit
of difference
you know that's what liz cheney's been
spending every day doing like kevin
mccarthy yesterday
he was uh he was specifically asked
about they said listen we're not
questioning who the president is we just
met with him five seconds ago
the conference will decide but i don't
think anybody is questioning the
legitimacy of the presidential election
i think that is all over with
we're sitting here with the president
today um
so from that point of view i don't think
that's a problem okay meanwhile
cheney is receiving exactly what you
would expect the strange and respect the
media
you think that liz cheney house number
three would be being interviewed by
savannah guthrie on national tv
if this weren't happening the media are
all over this because they don't want to
cover the actual news
okay this is not a big news story i'm
sorry an internal house battle
is not a big news story it's certainly
not a bigger news story than the fact
that the entire
house infrastructure for the democrats
last year refused to condemn ilhanov for
open anti-semitism so she just keeps
being an anti-semite
but the media didn't cover that either
in the same way this is blanket
wall-to-wall kind of stuff
because they need trump trump is a
distraction trump is the shiny object
trump is the misdirection and liz cheney
will substitute for trump
because she by didn't of what she's
talking about makes from the issue
so here is liz cheney with savannah
guthrie again
is this something that that a house gop
number three should be doing interviews
with msnbc's savannah guthrie
on the today show about how terrible the
other republicans are
do you think leader mccarthy has placed
his own ambitions
to be speaker of the house above
principle
i think that he is not leading with
principal right now
and i think that it is it's sad and i
think it's dangerous and i think that
we are at a moment where the republican
party has to have leaders that are
focused on principle i mean
i'm i'm sorry well which which
principles are you talking about because
it turns out that there are several
different principles of play
one is focusing on the principle that we
don't lie about elections
agree then there is the principle of
stop the people in power from wrecking
the country are you doing that
really that's kind of a priority okay
i think it's a pretty good indicator
that you might be headed down the wrong
path here when jenn sackey from the
white house is praising you
it's disturbing to see any leader
regardless of party being
attacked for simply speaking the truth
and as the president said
last week it's hard to understand
but our belief his belief is that the
american people will have to make their
own decisions
about whether the reaction by the people
they elected to represent them
should be embracing and elevating
conspiracies and attacks on our
democracy
or whether it should be standing up for
ideals that have historically been owned
by both democrats and republicans
representing
i'm sorry being lectured about election
veracity by the same democrats who
claimed for four years that trump was a
a russian catspaw and suggested al gore
was president and suggest that die bold
machines decided the 2004 election and
who keep elevating stacey abrams who
still refuses to acknowledge that she
was not legitimately elected the
governor of georgia like
spare me spare me just a little bit by
the way how much do the media love this
story which is
the reason that liz cheney ain't in
leadership is because the media loved
this story so much how much did the
media love this story
according to the folks over at
newsbuster's curtis hook reporting
cnn spent nearly three times more
time on liz cheney in 12 hours than all
of the economic crisis that are hitting
the country right now
very very clear what exactly the agenda
here is who's got two thumbs and wants
you to like and subscribe